bien merci bonjour
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Françoise ça m'aide bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous mère de
Dijon président de la Fédération
progressiste dont on va parler on est
ensemble pendant un peu plus de 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien Lecuyer de la
Voix du Nord bonjour monsieur
congrès des mères dans quelques instants
mais d'abord un mot sur une question
d'actualité c'est l'assurance chômage
puisque Olivier du soft a présenté sa
nouvelle réforme il y a quelques jours
elle vise à moduler l'indemnisation en
fonction de la conjoncture la durée
d'indemnisation va baisser de 25%
premier février pour les nouveaux
chômeurs est-ce que vous l'ancien
ministre du Travail vous auriez pu
porter cette réforme est-ce que j'aurais
porté cette réforme ça dépend de la
période parce que la vérité aujourd'hui
c'est que les Français ne comprennent
pas le marché du travail excusez-moi de
parler comme ça pourquoi parce que ils
ont ils entendent ils voient qu'il y a
plus de 300 000 emplois non pourvu et ou
en même temps qu'il y a plus de 3
millions ou 3 millions de chômeurs donc
ils disent il y a quelque chose qui ne
va pas quand j'étais mise du travail
j'ai répété à l'envie qu'il y avait 350
000 postes non pourvu mais aujourd'hui
c'est encore pire que ça il y a des
métiers en tension en grande tension sur
des métiers qui ne demandent pas une
grande formation a priori je dis bien a
priori et qui ne trouve pas preneur et
donc je pense que c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que se trouve à cet instant du
shop et le gouvernement pour dire
comment on peut améliorer cela donc à
partir du 1er février ce que vous avez
dit est juste il y aura une une baisse
mais pas pour tous les les
professionnels j'ai vérifié que les
intermittents du spectacle sont écartés
de cela l'idée c'est de valoriser le
travail à la place de l'indemnité c'est
une belle vous me sentez gênée parce que
c'est une baisse incontestablement je
vais pas dire le contraire des
indemnisations avant pour un jour
travailler on avait un jour qui pouvait
être ainsi indemnisé aujourd'hui on va
être à 7
ça reste quand même il faut le dire le
degré d'indemnisation plus élevé
d'Europe donc il faut relativiser
toujours ce genre de choses bon moi je
préférerais que ça se passe tout ça en
accord avec les organisations syndicales
dans le cadre d'un dialogue social mais
il est difficile parce que aujourd'hui
le dialogue social il est un peu
interrompu on va dire et je compte sur
Olivier du choc pour le remettre
oui je la comprends je la comprends pour
les raisons que comme les Français je
préfère le travail à l'indemnisation
voilà c'est vrai que quand vous voyez
des restaurants des hôtels qui ne
peuvent plus fonctionner parce qu'il
manque de personnel et que vous avez des
gens indemnisés au chômage j'avais créé
la prime d'activité pour valoriser le
travail par rapport justement au chômage
faut dire la vérité
oui grand Metz des des élus locaux qui
se déroule à la Porte de Versailles à
Paris jusqu'à demain le président de la
République alors il pratique une formule
inédite c'est cette année jamais vu pour
un président il boude le Congrès des
mers il y aura pas de discours
présidentiel demain mais par contre il
s'agore il s'accorde une grande
déambulation cet après-midi au salon des
mers est-ce qu'il a raison de pratiquer
ça est-ce que est-ce que c'est une
défiance vis-à-vis du Congrès des mères
et de l'Association des maires de France
et puis une question est-ce que vous
serez avec le président cet après-midi
je serai cet après-midi au salon des
mers alors est-ce que je serais avec le
président non puisque j'y serai à titre
personnel je le croiserai peut-être je
le saluerai bien évidemment et est-ce
qu'il a raison bon je ne sais pas où ça
va on est à peu près tout vu des
présidents qui venaient pas des
présidents qui venaient des premiers
ministres qui représentaient le
président de la République est-ce que
cette formule du discours excatedrale
qu'on pourrait presque dire à un sens
vraiment
oui parce qu'on entend le président de
dans sa relation avec avec les maires
mais je crois que la chose a évolué
c'est-à-dire je pense que depuis le
mouvement des gilets jaunes il a compris
qu'il y avait une autre relation à avoir
avec les maires il veut des choses plus
directes j'ai l'impression on verra plus
direct mais pas d'annonce on nous
signale à l'Élysée que tout a tous les
dispositifs sont en place ils vont pas
réinventer la roue c'est les mots d'un
conseiller éliséen est-ce qu'il faut pas
malgré tout que le le président de la
République rassure des élus qui voit
2023 comme une période de crise multiple
alors il y a aujourd'hui une grande une
grande crainte d'une partie des mères
des élus pourquoi parce que il y a de
plus en plus d'exigences de la
population je crois que la sortie de la
covid l'a montré les gens les citoyens
sont beaucoup plus demandeurs de réponse
rapide d'efficacité on donne on demande
beaucoup aux maires et on leur donne pas
toujours la possibilité d'assumer
cette responsabilité qu'on leur confie
en quelque sorte et les nos concitoyens
voient souvent les mers comme des
prestataires de services plus que
d'autres choses qui aujourd'hui vous
n'avez pas ce pouvoir d'agir c'est le
thème du Congrès vous n'avez pas le
sentiment de l'avoir je ne dirais pas ça
je suis maire d'une grande ville et je
peux vous dire que j'agis et je peux
vous dire que la ville de Dijon est une
ville qui a un pointe en matière
écologique et que la relation avec les
administrés est bonne mais pour autant
il y a l'ensemble des maires et donc
nous ne sommes pas un îlot de bonheur
dans un
océan de difficulté mais cela dit est-ce
que vous rejoignez l'association des
maires de France qui qui contestent
cette perte d'autonomie fiscale
représentée par la suppression de la
CVAE c'est un pot local sur les sur les
entreprises alors après la taxe
d'habitation supprimer elle aussi est-ce
que c'est un nouveau coup à l'autonomie
des communes alors moi je vais vous
répondre tout à fait clairement c'est un
engagement du Président de la République
pris dans le cadre sa campagne
présidentielle mais c'est surtout
j'allais dire une ponction
supplémentaire encore sur les finances
publiques parce que c'est un
remboursement de l'ordre de 4 milliards
d'euros de la CVAE pour pour moitié
puisque vous le savez ça va être fait en
deux parties moi j'aurais préféré qu'il
supprime la C3S qui impactent plus je le
crois que la CVAE les entreprises j'ai
essayé de plaider je plais encore pour
dire la CVAE n'est pas un impôt de
production c'est un impôt sur la valeur
ajoutée de l'entreprise sur ce qui est
produit et donc pas sur en amont de la
production mais bon c'est la décision du
Président de la République vous demandez
encore son maintien vous y croyez vous
mais on le dit dans le cadre des débats
je vois les parlements les
parlementaires qui s'expriment sur ce
sur ce sujet
donc moi j'aurais préféré qu'on consomme
on supprime la C3S qui a un impôt qui
pèse lourd sur un certain nombre
d'entreprises sur la dotation globale de
fonctionnement alors le gouvernement dit
qu'elle augmente de manière inédite
depuis 13 ans mais les élus demandent
son indexation sur l'inflation vous
regrettez que le gouvernement refuse
cette indexation alors on peut pas on
peut pas tout avoir et tout faire donc
soyons clairs il y a une augmentation de
la DGF de l'ordre de 330 millions
d'euros c'est une bonne nouvelle 320
millions pardon mais je crois qu'ils en
ont rajouté 10 chercheurs mais
c'est c'est une bonne nouvelle on va pas
dire on va pas dire le contraire c'est
une bonne nouvelle et c'est vrai que
c'était assez inédit puisque on a connu
dans la période François Hollande une
forte diminution de la DGF elle a été
maintenue un peu renié mais enfin
maintenu globalement sous le premier
quinquennat de d'Emmanuel Macron et là
elle est maintenue et augmenter
légèrement donc c'est une c'est une
bonne nouvelle en soi pour autant ce qui
aujourd'hui inquiète les mères c'est
qu'elle va être le relèvement du niveau
des bases est-ce que nous allons avoir
un relèvement qui va être au niveau de
l'inflation ou pas parce que
les finances de nos communes sont
fortement impactés par la crise
énergétique et dans les alors il y a un
bouclier qui a été mis en place pour les
petites communes pour le moment mais
nous nous battons pour que les grandes
communes le soient j'ai en tête deux ou
trois exemples de de grandes villes qui
voient leurs factures énergétique
multipliées par vous pour Dijon ça
représente quoi par deux je peux donner
un exemple à peu près précis c'était 10
millions d'euros pour la ville on parle
c'est 20 millions d'euros l'année
prochaine donc d'accord c'est c'est pas
rien et donc l'amortisseur tarifaire
dont le gouvernement parle
chose qui nous intéresse mais oui pour
le moment la chose n'est pas très
précise et donc on n'arrive pas à savoir
exactement quelles vont être les
communes ville qui vont être couvertes
par heure vous attendez peut-être
d'Elisabeth borne qui doit prononcer le
discours demain à la place du président
qu'elle précise c'est ces modalités je
voudrais dire que il y a un bon contact
avec avec la première ministre quel est
elle a pris en compte un certain nombre
de demandes pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
décision autoritaire et
soit prise comme ça a pu l'être du temps
de de l'ancien Premier ministre
d'Édouard Philippe avec les contrats de
Cahors donc nous ne voulons pas de cela
encadrement des dépenses qui est prévu
vous le regrettez vous demandez on me
dit qu'il faut attendre je vais attendre
le discours de la première ministre
demain on nous dit qu'il fallait moi
j'avais rencontré au titre de France
urbaine puisque je préside la commission
des finances Gabriel Attal il y a un
mois et demi fin septembre on va dire et
nous avions nous étions convenus que il
n'y aurait pas de mesure type contrat de
Cahors ces revenus dans le débat c'est
reparti j'attends de voir en gros ce que
ce que je conteste c'est la nécessité de
de diminuer de 0,5% par rapport à
l'inflation nos dépenses de
fonctionnement ce que on nous demande
l'État ne le fait pas donc je pense que
il faut que tout le monde s'y mette pas
uniquement les mêmes David l'isnard
président de l'AMF passe par le de
paternalisme ambiant de la part de
l'État est-ce que c'est des mots que
vous reprendriez non non je pense qu'il
y a une il y a quelque chose qui se
passe à Bercy qui a pas beaucoup changé
c'est qu'on considère les maires les
élus locaux d'une manière générale comme
des dépensiers c'est un principe à Bercy
alors que c'est extrêmement rigoureux
nous savons tous que l'État est d'une
rigueur absolue sur ces déficites comme
on peut le voir tous les jours puisque
on est à plus de 5%. donc ça se passe
bien avec Elisabeth borne ne vous
attendez des actes quand même
et que le à travers toutes les
procédures de 49,3 il n'y a pas de
louper il y a un sujet que vous suivez
particulièrement évidemment depuis des
années ce sont les questions de sécurité
les élus les agressions envers les élus
qui augmentent considérablement est-ce
que vous vous sentez suffisamment
protégé est-ce qu'il faut durcir encore
les sanctions contre les agresseurs
d'élus selon vous je pense qu'il faut
surtout les appliquer les sanctions le
problème il est là le problème il est
que on a depuis 20 ans négligé
globalement tous les gouvernements qui
se sont succédés
on négligé la justice je pense que nous
manquons de magistrats et
y compris le gouvernement socialiste
bien sûr il avait légèrement augmenté il
y a une reprise sous François Hollande
je me rappelle très bien mais c'était
insuffisant pour dire que on était dans
une période de contrôle des dépenses je
le rappelle savoir revenir ça va revenir
on peut pas rester vous l'avez bien vu
avec 5% de déficit déjà on nous dit le
FMI nous interpelle c'est exactement la
situation quand on Hollande est arrivée
et donc il n'empêche que les postes sont
en augmentation avec du pond-moretti il
y a une augmentation du nombre de
magistrats mais il y a un tel retard
aujourd'hui il y a un tel retard que il
n'est pas normal que des sanctions
soient prises par les magistrats un an
un an et demi deux ans après des faits
mais est-ce que vous voyez comme vos
collègues qui se sont exprimés dans
cette enquête du Cevipof avec l'AMF
est-ce que vous observez cette montée de
la violence à l'égard des des élus c'est
même cette violence dans les dans les
mots cette atmosphère de défiance alors
même que selon les baromètres politiques
les élus locaux sont parmi ceux qui
obtiennent le plus de confiance de la
part des administrés je peux encore me
promener tranquillement dans les rues de
boulot sans être agressé et je suis pas
le seul mais c'est ça rejoint mes propos
de du début à savoir il y a une exigence
plus grande et il y a effectivement une
nervosité j'essaie de dire les chosesias
il y a une il y a une sorte de violence
contenue dans la société depuis cette
crise la covid un horizon qui qui n'est
pas éclairci le sentiment que la guerre
à nos portes il faut quand même parler
de choses comme celle-là que l'inflation
est là rogne le pouvoir de l'achat que
les prix augmentent mais je voudrais
aussi rappeler que nous sommes un pays
qui a une hyperprotection une très bonne
protection quand même des populations
nous avons eu le taux d'inflation quand
même le plus bas d'Europe le plus bas ça
compte tout ça c'est des points de
croissance derrière donc moi je voudrais
pas quand même être celui Qui qui crie
au loup sans raison il y a un autre
sujet dans l'actualité c'est la
politique migratoire avec la gestion de
l'echen Viking un de vos anciens
compagnons de route à partir de
socialiste Gérard Collomb à vivement
critiqué cette décision il a mis en
garde des manuel Macron c'était son
premier ministre de l'Intérieur et il a
parlé dans d'une brèche créant un
précédent est-ce que une semaine 10
jours après l'arrivée de nos chaînes
Viking l'effet lui ont donné raison non
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec avec
la potion de Gérard Collomb je pense que
le Président de la République a eu
raison tout à fait clairement ça sera
pas un appel d'air il est on peut pas
laisser mourir des gens comme ça devant
vous en mer à quelques kilomètres des
côtes il l'a fait par contre je pense
qu'il y a des mesures à prendre
aujourd'hui il faut réviser la
circulaire Valls de de 2012 parce que
tout notre système d'accueil il y a une
tradition d'accueil dans ce pays et
notamment tous ceux qui réclament et
nous allons continuer à l'appliquer je
le pays doit continuer à l'appliquer
mais pour autant et tout le système est
embouteillé excusez-moi de l'expression
parce que nous avons en France des
milliers et des milliers de Nini de ni
expulsables ni régularisable c'est à
dire qu'ils sont en France depuis plus
de 5 ans et ils peuvent prétendre à un
titre de séjour puisqu'ils sont en
France depuis plus de 5 ans c'est la
circulaire Valls de 2012 mais pour
autant pour avoir ce type de séjour il
faut qu'ils aient un contrat de travail
et pour avoir le contrat de travail il
faut qu'ils aient le titre de séjour
alors moi je suis pour que on régularise
beaucoup plus ceux qui sont là depuis 5
ans dans des conditions de formation et
d'accueil qu'il faut vérifier sur la
langue sur etc mais ces gens sont là ils
ont envie de travailler et aujourd'hui
on manque de bras excusez-moi
l'Allemagne a montré un exemple en la
matière on manque de bras je pense qu'il
faudrait régulariser ses Nini papa
globalement et tout mais le faire au fil
de l'eau et ça serait Darmanin et sa loi
immigration justement qui évoque cette
possibilité de de
dans des métiers en tension pour des
personnes qui ne disposeraient pas de je
soutiens ça surprend tout le monde mais
je soutiens la démarche de Gérald
Darmanin il a pris conscience de la
difficulté de la chose il a pris aussi
conscience de la violence qui se répand
dans cette société et donc nous avons
plus de policiers je rappelle que il a
fallu compenser je me permets de le dire
comme ça les 10000 policiers qui ont été
supprimés sur Nicolas Sarkozy on va
parler politique on va parler de la
fédération en progressiste que vous
présidez est-ce que vous êtes encore
socialiste Françoise je suis encore un
homme de gauche on va parler comme ça je
suis un homme de gauche mais je suis un
social démocrate et donc
on pourrait dire à socialiste
social-démocrate si vous le voulez mais
il y a on pourrait définir c'est-à-dire
que je suis universaliste je suis laïque
je suis républicain je suis écologiste
et je suis en même temps et fermement
européen et donc
macroniste pour moi c'est je soutiens
président de la République qui présente
des bonnes réformes et je critique quand
il représente les mauvaises et ça ne me
gêne pas d'avoir c'est quoi les
mauvaises d'avoir dit par exemple moi je
vous ai donné l'exemple de la CVL je
pense que il aurait mieux fallu faire la
C3S ça c'est pas une bonne mesure voilà
après j'appelle le dialogue social dans
tout ce qui concerne la réforme du de
l'assurance de l'indemnisation du
chômage ou sur les retraites il faut
absolument que soit prise en compte la
pénibilité etc donc moi je suis pas
macroniste au sens de Macron je j'ai
soutenu le président de la République
j'ai dit je suis un homme de gauche qui
vote Emmanuel Macron je ne le regrette
pas donc aider le premier tour voilà
c'est assez simple pour autant je suis
pas béni oui oui et la Fédération
progressiste elle a pour vocation avec
d'autres sans hégémonie en bienveillance
c'est des mots qu'il faut employer en ce
moment dans la vie publique en
bienveillance de rassembler toutes
celles et tous ceux qui veulent bien
travailler à essayer d'élaborer un
projet social-démocrate justement
socialiste
progressiste puisque vous lancez la
Fédération progressiste vous l'avez
lancé officiellement de au début du mois
là avec Juliette mehadel exporte-parole
du Parti socialiste et ancienne
secrétaire d'État de François Hollande
mais quels sont les projets de
dorénavant qu'est-ce que vous avez
compté mettre en place pour justement
pallier les déficits que vous notez
envers le PS d'abord de de d'élaborer de
travailler à l'élaboration d'un projet
c'est-à-dire de multiplier des
rencontres sur des thèmes avec des
personnalités qui viendraient animer ces
débats pour que pendant les deux ou
trois années qui viennent tous les
sociaux-démocrates qui se reconnaissent
d'abord sur une méthode cette méthode
c'est l'éloge du compromis et j'ai
rappelé Henri Weber avait fait un livre
très intéressant sur ce sujet les
logiques compromis c'est-à-dire la
recherche du compromis plutôt que
l'affrontement l'opposition stérile
comme on peut le voir à l'Assemblée
nationale de la part de la nupes je ne
parle même pas de l'ex à droite et donc
nous allons
je critique la nuit pêche je ne suis pas
du tout sur cette ligne là j'ai dit que
j'étais européen donc c'est déjà un
point de divergence profond d'autre part
je pense qu'il faut chercher les
compromis dans l'intérêt général je ne
pense pas que l'affrontement aujourd'hui
c'est une manière de de se conforter
dans la vie publique ou de s'affronter
moi je suis pour chercher des relations
de compromis avec le gouvernement
améliorer la situation des de nos
concitoyens et pas la révolution et
voilà le gouvernement n'existe plus
selon vous ben non elle a disparu il
faut la recréer il faut la recréer par
un projet par des débats nous aurons à
nouveau rendez-vous que je fixerai
disons fin janvier début février je
comptais je compte invité par exemple
quelqu'un tout à fait intéressant qui
s'appelle Juliano dans police Caroline
fourrez voyez on va on va on va
travailler on va faire des propositions
d'abord il doit y avoir une liste
sociale démocrate pour les Européens
pour les européenne bien évidemment il
doit y avoir la prochaine fois le
président de la République de se
représentera pas il faut qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui porte un projet mais ce
projet il faut pas faire ce qu'a fait
Anne Hidalgo il faut le préparer
longtemps à l'avance et il faut avoir un
vrai projet moi par exemple je propose
de travailler pour le moment sur le
partage de la valeur j'ai vu que c'est
un sujet dont le président de la
République oui mais vous savez
aujourd'hui dans le dans le partage
entre le capitalisme et les forces
sociales et bien ce sont les les
salariés qui sont aujourd'hui pénalisés
et donc il faut qu'il retrouve de la de
la valeur ajoutée qui soit partagée avec
eux selon quelle forme quelle relation
entre le travail et le capital tout ça
il faut le remettre sur les gens
ça RA est-ce que vous espérez attirer à
vous les déçus du PS qui ne veulent pas
de l'accord de laine donc vous les
appelez Bernard Cazeneuve Stéphane Le
folle
je les ai appelé au téléphone j'ai j'ai
changé et on dit il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on travaille ensemble tous ensemble
on oubliant les petites histoires mais
surtout qu'on travaille sur le fond et
je pense que ça mène je suis désolé mais
on a l'impression qu'elle heure actuelle
chacun est en l'occurrence dans son
couloir Stéphane Le Foll poursuit sa
stratégie Jean-Christophe gambadélis
monte aussi sa propre initiative vous
également au final de progrès
il est dans René est-ce que tous ces
gens-là est-ce que tous ces gens-là
peuvent se retrouver à un moment donné
selon vous oui il le faut je pense il le
faut et c'est ce qu'on s'est dit il faut
trouver
des anciens socialistes des soutiens
d'Emmanuel Macron qui pourront pas
soutenir Emmanuel Macron dans 3 ans dans
4 ans parce qu'il sera plus candidat
donc bien sûr il faut qu'on travaille
ensemble tous ceux qui veulent faire
avancer les idées
universaliste laïque républicaine
écologique et est-ce que François
il doit participer à la réflexion il a
beaucoup à nous apprendre il a été
président de la République voilà c'est
pas parce que il a pas il sait pas
représenté et que ça c'est soldé par un
échec que il n'a pas une expérience
personnelle des choses on doit on doit
changer gémonie aujourd'hui je nous ne
sommes pas là aucune volonté gemonique
là la Fédération d'ailleurs pour le
prouver on a dit on peut avoir la double
adhésion donc je dis venez rejoindre la
Fédération progressiste venez travailler
grâce à où je peux le dire venez
travailler avec nous rencontrez-nous il
y aura des il y aura des essais il y
aura des publications et on propose à
tout le monde de se rassembler quel est
le risque selon vous d'un échec de votre
initiative est-ce que ce serait pour
vous finalement donner les clés de du
socialisme à Olivier Faure et donc d'une
certaine manière de le lier à la France
insoumise mais il est déjà lié à la
France insoumise c'est bien ça le
problème vous avez vu quand même que ils
ont présenté une motion de censure
ensemble j'ai dit moi j'ai eu une
situation à peu près identique au niveau
de la région Bourgogne dans le temps
puisque Jean-Pierre Soisson avait été
élu avec des voix d'extrême droite à
l'époque et jamais je présidais le
groupe socialiste à la région jamais
nous n'avons voté avec les voix du Front
national nous rejoignant il suffisait de
mettre un amendement qui permettait
d'éviter cela ça n'a pas été fait moi je
pense que aujourd'hui le Parti
socialiste tel qu'il est maintenu il est
dans la soumission vis-à-vis de la
nupesse parce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est une personnalité elle est beaucoup
plus forte qu'Olivier fort c'est lui qui
emporte le mouvement
dans sa situation là tel qu'il est non
et d'abord il faudrait commencer par
travailler d'abord il faudrait non
monsieur que non quels sont les
propositions que vous avez vues avancées
par le Parti socialiste le partage de la
valeur la relation capitale travaille
dans tout ça c'est c'était dans le bon
vieux temps j'ai envie de dire c'est
fini
ça veut dire que lui il la vocation à
vous rejoindre c'est quoi la différence
entre vous et territoires de progrès
totalement indépendants de renaissance
nous sommes la jambe gauche si vous le
voulez de l'associal démocratie mais
nous ne sommes pas dans un Macron j'ai
été pour l'élection présidentielle un
homme de gauche qui a appelé à voter
Emmanuel Macron mais il faut il faut
bien comprendre les choses je crois que
le la vision que peut avoir Emmanuel
Macron c'est de créer un grand parti
démocrate moi je pense qu'il faut créer
un parti social-démocrate c'est pas la
même chose exactement il manque social
dedans vous nous confirmez que de
certains départs de territoire de
progrès pour vous rejoindre Gilles
Savary Yves Durand c'est ce qu'ils ont
publié c'est ce qu'ils ont dit j'étais
venu à ma réunion mais nous nous sommes
sans hégémonie s'ils veulent rester ils
peuvent j'ai dit qu'on pouvait avoir la
double adhésion la Fédération
progressiste à la vocation à permettre
les débats à rassembler et à élaborer un
projet avec d'autres avant d'être en
partie
oui plus un mouvement d'ailleurs mais
c'est un parti puisque déposé le
statuts dont de nombreux maires de
gauche Martine Aubry Anne Hidalgo vous
avez décidé de ne pas boycoter la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar alors j'espère que
vous avez profité du match hier soir la
Coupe du Monde sera diffusée et diffusée
sur écran géant
vous dites comme Macron il faut pas
mélanger politique et sport non j'ai dit
il faut pas d'hypocrite c'est sûr de ça
que j'ai dit parce que ceux qui ont
appelé au boycott alors que pendant 12
ans ils n'ont rien dit moi dès le début
j'ai dénoncé le fait que l'accord
visiblement le voyez bien qui avait été
élaboré sous Nicolas Sarkozy encore lui
il était il était bancal et il était en
faveur du Qatar il y avait quelque chose
qui n'allait pas à ce moment là je l'ai
dénoncé mais maintenant place au
football moi c'est ce que je crois et
d'ailleurs ça va faire avancer les
droits au Qatar et d'ailleurs on voit
déjà on peut on peut permettre comme ça
allez-y Rania
et de ne pas chanter l'hymne national en
soutien au mouvement iraniens
en fait à la différence de ce que dit
Emmanuel Macron mais je ne veux pas
critiquer les propos de du président de
la République d'accord bon merci
beaucoup
d'être venu la Une de La Voix du Nord
c'est sûr en fait agent du fils
l'acte serait prémédité c'est à la Une
de La Voix du Nord merci Julien merci
beaucoup François personnel on passe au
club des territoires